Just be who you are Selena.
No one cares about what you’re doing.
It’s about who I am.
Being okay with where I am.
I am grateful to be alive.
Selena Gomez
Was diagnosed with lupus,
depression and anxiety.
She had a mental breakdown.
Let me make a promise.
I am going to stop living like this.
How do I learn to breathe my own breath again?
If anybody saw what I saw
they wouldn’t have recognized her.
Like my whole life since I was a kid I’ve been working.
And I don’t wanna be like super famous.
But I do know that if I’m
here that I have to use that for good.
What’s holding you back from doing it?
That I’m not good enough.
That’s something that I felt a lot of growing up.
In this life, you have to show people empathy.
Have a chance to give people more than what you receive.
What makes me happy is connection
and it helps me get out of my head.
Do you know who this is?
[Screaming]
Yes she’s real.
Mommy went to school with her.
Clearly I’m still here to use
whatever I have to help someone else.
♪My mind and me. We don’t get along sometimes
and it gets hard to breathe but I wouldn’t change my life.♪
Everything that I have gone through,
it’s gonna be there.
I’m just making it my friend now.
I am happier and I’m in control
of my emotions and thoughts more than I have ever been.
I think that you are saving lives.
I know that you’re saving lives, so thank you.
I just hope that I’m a part of the
conversation ya know?
♪If somebody sees me like this then they
won’t feel alone.♪
I know this is the beginning for me.
♪My mind and me.♪
I love you.